[Music]
when people ask me for some ideas about
how to approach clearing clutter um
there are some that come up over and
over now I have a lot of ideas some work
for some people and not for others so
nothing's Universal but there are some
that people seem to find particularly
helpful that really do strike a chord
and one is the X Factor so this is when
you're trying to imagine an outfit or
you know a shirt or a skirt or a pair of
pants ask yourself if I was wearing this
item and I ran into my ex on the street
what I feel good that I was wearing this
item or what I really wish that I was
wearing something else and if it fails
the X Factor test it's probably
something that you can give away another
thing to keep in mind when you're
clearing clutter is to be think about
other people I mean imagine for in the
future you're gone your stuff is still
there and everybody's arriving at your
place and having to deal with your stuff
don't force other people to deal with
your clutter think about it now like are
they gonna want to deal with this broken
bread maker or can you take care of that
now should you go through all those
paperbacks that are falling into pieces
now or should you wait for somebody else
to have to do it once you're gone one
really helpful thing to do is to create
a mystery box because we've all had this
experience where like there's a cord but
what is it a cord to or there's an
attachment to the vacuum cleaner is it
important is it not important in my
family it's remote controls we have all
of these kind of loose remote controls
floating around and I'm like I don't
even know exactly what it controls other
than it controls something remotely but
what is it I don't know but they do feel
important they often look important um
and so we can be reluctant to get rid of
them one thing you can do is you can
create a box and put everything in there
if you're not sure exactly if it's
useful if it's necessary put it in the
box so if you're all of a sudden looking
for a cord you could think ah I bet I
put it in the box I put the date on the
box when you start it and after a year
if you haven't gone in there to get
anything out well then you can get rid
of everything in the box one of my
favorite clutter clearing tips is
something that I figured out for myself
because I noticed that sometimes I'd be
like walking through my house or looking
through a clause that are recovered and
I
I think should I get rid of this and I
would ponder it and then I'd be like I
guess I'll keep it and then I you know
some time would go by and then I'd find
myself walking by and I think do I
really need this I think I'll keep it
and now I'm like probably I should have
gotten rid of it the first time it
occurred to me but now if it's occurred
to me three times that I should toss
something recycle something or give
something away I say I'm ready to let go
of that thing three strikes you're out
one thing to think about as you're
clearing clutter is can you put the
spaces in your home to their correct use
um research shows that about 25% of
people in the United States don't use
their garage because they can't get
their car in they're using their garage
for storage and similarly people have
Sun porches which are full of junk they
have rooms that can be libraries or
music rooms or guest rooms or yoga rooms
or meditation rooms or solariums they
could be anything except they somehow
become a junk room so if you have a room
in your house that's being used not for
an idea that you want it to be used for
that or maybe it's supposed to be
dedicated to an entirely different
purpose ask yourself would it make us
happier as a household if we actually
could dine in our dining room or
actually put our car in our garage
because often when we get rid of
everything we don't need don't use don't
love then we open up these spaces for a
use that's actually much more satisfying
one of them my favorite tips about how
to clear clutter and create outer order
is the one minute rule and I have to say
for my sister Elizabeth who's the
co-host of my happier podcast this is
the rule that she says this helped her
the most so the one minute rule is that
if there's something that you can do in
less than a minute do it without delay
so if you can print something out and
file it and delete the email if you can
hang up your coat if you can put
something in the garbage instead of just
like throwing it on the floor or leaving
it next to your computer on your desk go
ahead and do it and what this does is
that in these little tiny increments of
time you know so you're not having to
spend a lot of time energy or money on
clearing clutter just in these little
interspecies of your life you're getting
rid of sort of that scum on the surface
of life that's those little tiny
tasks that are inconsequential on their
own but they build up and we've all had
the feeling of walking into an office or
walking to your desk or getting in your
car walking into your bedroom and
thinking oh my gosh I want to walk right
out again because I just see all this
stuff I have to clog my way through the
one minute rule keeps these things from
accumulating and that just gives us a
much more a much richer sense of kind of
optimism and energy and just more space
to move around as we go through our day
[Music]